Check out this week's must-see movies.
Can't you just be a friendly neighborhood Spider-Man?
Peter Parker has to balance his superhero alter ego with normal high school life in "Spider-Man: Homecoming".
Yeah! Spider-man!
They work in secret and under constant threat. They are real journalistic heroes.
See the untold story of a group of journalists fighting against ISIS in the documentary "City of Ghosts".
And they will kill all of us.
Casey Affleck stars in "A Ghost Story", a surreal indie drama about a recently deceased man,
whose spirit watches over his grieving wife.
We do what we can to endure.
See what's hot in theaters with this week's fanticipation.
So what's your weekend ticket going to be? Let us know by commenting. See you next time on weekend ticket.